en décembre dernier le radiotélescope
d'arecibo à porto rico a été détruit par
l'effondrement d'une de ces structures
ça a marqué la fin d'un des symboles de
la radioastronomie qui a permis de faire
des observations exceptionnelle de notre
galaxie
au coeur de l'île de porto rico
niché au creux de montagnes luxuriantes
repose un immense trésor un oeil géant
braqué sur le cosmos le radiotélescope
d'arecibo pendant près de six décennies
des générations de chercheurs y ont
observé l'espace comme nulle part
ailleurs vision fait des découvertes
majeures
je suis éliminé par un doctorat en
astrophysique à l'université mégalo
depuis 2015
emilie parents compter sur le télescope
d'arecibo pour mener ses travaux
sa spécialité la recherche de pulsar les
ans quelques semaines à l'automne tout
s'est effondré
littéralement
sur l'écran des 1000 par an les
commandes sont prêtes comme figé dans le
temps depuis le 10 août dernier jusqu'à
la l'astrophysicienne prenait
régulièrement le contrôle du télescope à
distance depuis montréal pour observer
la galaxie quand l'appareil a subi un
premier bris à la fin de l'été ces
recherches ont connu une fin abrupte
j'observais la veille tout allait bien
et on avait une grosse campagne
d'observation qui emmenait donc on avait
prévu observés je pense qu'on a mis des
observations prévu à tout les jours ça
t'amène yeux j'attendais avec impatience
et observations la menicon était prêt
pour observer ça s'est pas produit
l'observatoire d'arecibo est uniquement
sa construction a commencé en 1960 avec
pour premier objectif l'étude de la
haute atmosphère
puis il est vite devenu une star de la
recherche astronomique son antenne fait
305 mètres de diamètre
au dessus 3 tours soutiennent une série
de câbles qui supporte une plateforme de
900 tonnes sur laquelle reposent les
instruments les signaux venus de
l'espace sont réfléchis sur l'antenne
fixe puis capté par le récepteur mobile
grâce à sa taille arecibo pouvait voir
jusque dans les coins les plus reculés
de notre galaxie avec une sensibilité
inégalée
rien qu'à la la sensibilité de sa
bouille avait rien qui était sensible
qui a pas demandé sinon si faible car
ces mots c'était vraiment la grande
force ce télescope
le télescope d'arecibo regarder
l'invisible la lumière se propage sous
forme d'ondés électromagnétiques dont la
fréquence de situations varient une
partie de ce spectre forme la lumière et
les couleurs que nous percevons le
radiotélescope lui capte des ondes de
plus basses fréquences invisibles à
l'oeil nu les ondes radio parmi les
objets célestes qui émettent des ondes
radio il y a les pulsars des cadavres
des toiles qui ont explosé et dont il ne
reste que le noyau hyper massif on va se
retrouver un objet qui fait environ la
taille de montréal mais qui a une fois
et demie la masse soleil ou plus donc
c'est extrêmement dense et les affaires
les objets les plus denses dans
l'univers très très compact une énorme
gravité et certains vont tomber très
rapidement le plus celui qu'on connaît
qui le plus rapide
il tourne 700 fois sur lui même par
seconde alors paul les pulsars émettent
des jed ondes radio
vu de la terre et se transforme alors en
farr cosmique
si le jet radio est aligné avec la peur
à un moment dans la rotation du pulsar
nous avec nos télescopes
on reçoit impulse de lumière radio dans
nos télescopes donc à chaque rotation du
pulsar
on va voir un bébé donc c'est vraiment
de la même façon que si on était un
bateau sur les os et qu'on voyait un
fort sur la côte on voit justin un flash
de lumière
c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on voit les
puces or depuis 2004 le projet de
recherches auxquelles participent emilie
parents a découvert grâce à arecibo plus
de 200 pulsar dans notre galaxie sont
les quelques 3000 connu au fil des ans
le télescope a permis de nombreuses
autres avancées scientifiques
il a permis de préciser la vitesse de
rotation de mercure produit des cartes
inédites de planètes et d'astéroïdes et
même confirmé l'existence des ondes
gravitationnelles prédite par la théorie
de la relativité générale d'einstein
emilie parents s'étaient rendus arecibo
en 2019
une visite exceptionnelle et inoubliable
c'était juste tellement impressionnant
j'avais jamais je vais jamais rien comme
ça je
je peux imaginer mais l'âge d'or du
télescope était derrière lui son statut
fragilisé par les difficultés de
financement par son emplacement aussi
sujet aux tremblements de terre et aux
ouragans
le dissout dernier un câble auxiliaire
cède et endommage gravement une partie
de l'antenne les observations sont
interrompues le temps de planifier des
réparations d'urgence puis le 6 novembre
c'est un câble principal qui se brise
l'observatoire est évacué à cause des
risques d'effondrement on annonce le
démantèlement d'arecibo
le 1er décembre nouvelle rupture de
câbles il inéluctable ce produit
[Musique]
c'était vraiment un breaking crève coeur
vraiment de voir cette vidéo lost est
impressionnant en même temps mais ça
fait mal et ça va mal aussi beaucoup
pour la communauté marocaine s'était pas
justin un outil scientifique c'était
vraiment aussi un outil un outil pour
l'éducation est aussi un une bonne
source de revenus pour le tourisme la
disparition du radiotélescope d'arecibo
laisse une plaie béante dans la jungle
de porto rico comme dans la communauté
scientifique
en attendant d'avoir accès à de nouveaux
télescopes aussi sensible emilie parents
à tourner son regard vers un autre
observatoire plus petits aux états unis
dans un projet aussi avec le greenback
télescope occidentale quel meilleur mais
servier lui tombera pas
[Musique]